hey guys it's justine and today we are
about to embark on a lego super mario
challenge a huge thank you to lego for
sponsoring this video and making one of
my dream videos come true ever since
they announced these
one of the things that i really wanted
to do was make a huge
massive course in my house so to get
things started and to use the entire
lego super mario world you need the
starter kit
so this gives you mario your start pipe
and your end goal flag
this is what you need to start and this
is what you need to end with and what
you do
in between those is basically up to your
imagination
also in the set you get a little goomba
you get bowser jr and you get a coin
block
mario has a built-in gyroscope
accelerometer and speakers that react to
his movements and the bricks that he hit
there's even a sensor in the bottom to
make all of that possible and it's cool
because you can see all of the actions
take place in the lcd on his belly
[Music]
this is also a color sensor so it'll
react to different colored bricks so red
is fire
green is the ground yellow is sand and
blue is water
all of the expansion sets can be built
within the start and end goal
they also have some really cool
character packs and they have some power
ups for mario so you can change his
outfits and depending upon which outfit
you choose will determine how he reacts
to the course
we have lego mario which comes in the
starter kit there's builder mario
fire mario propeller mario and cat mario
so when you hit the start pipe mario
will put 60 seconds on his clock and
then you have to collect as many coins
as possible
there is a timer block that you can hit
that will give you an extra 30 seconds
but for this challenge we have to build
a course and collect as many coins as
possible
i'll put a link in the description where
you can find all of the lego mario sets
so now it's time to get started with my
lego super mario dream course
my house has been cleared out we have
over 500 lego base plates and we're
gonna cover the walls and the floors and
make one of the most fun
interactive lego super mario courses
that we can come up with
i'm so excited for this i have some of
the sets already built and some of them
we're going to be building and then
we're just going to go for it and see
what happens
my sister jenna is here and my friend ed
is here to assist with the building
process
and maddie's helping too helping
i'm gonna start building the first set
this is the
bowser expansion set ed and jenna are
gonna start working on figuring out
where the background elements are gonna
go
it's planning a waterfall coming off of
the fireplace this is going to be
[Music]
incredible
you so well what what are we doing here
do we what's
anyone
[Music]
you guys that time lapse sure made this
look like it was pretty quick huh
there's like towels of sweat below the
10 hours later
nobody can see
i'm gonna start working on the actual
course back here we also have another
little
like tv stand thing that i think i'm
gonna bring in here just to add like a
little
another extra level maybe put some grass
on that
it's gonna be cool
so i'm trying to link together the
ground and the water so we have a lot of
these really cool little elements that
we can just pop in
to kind of get each piece to start
flowing into the whole course
[Music]
i should have looked up what the clouds
look like before i made one
[Music]
15 hours later the course is officially
done
and we're going to go for the run
are you guys ready please say you are
because i have never been more ready
[Music]
so
oh
foreign
[Music]
148 this is crazy so this shows you
all of the coins that you got
from each thing that you hit 148.
[Applause]
hey
148 coins you guys this was probably one
of the most fun videos
not only to make but to work on and edit
and just see it all come together but
the fun isn't stopping here because i'm
tagging papa jake who is going to be
making a course and also running the
same challenge
i'll put a link in the description where
you can check out his channel and all of
the other creators who participated in
building a fun
lego super mario course i'll see you
guys the next video bye
[Music]